[Music]
so hello everyone
yeah I'm fo dis Matthias from primes and
from goal-driven
gonna talk about the stuff that we've
been doing at radio love so very much
thanks for having us so Red Hill up is a
consortium of local or regional I should
say Dutch news providers we've been
implementing a couple of data-driven
pilots there the the regional news
provider says should also innovate and
I'm gonna tell a little bit about pilots
Matthias is gonna tell a little bit
about primes IO which is the
personalization platform that we've been
using for this okay so they fill up if
you're from if you're Dutch you'll
probably recognize these names and icons
so it's a consortium of news providers
it's headed by over held alone so we are
going to earn them now and then to work
together at a local law and as we speak
more and more of these news providers
are hooking into the system and
providing the data so that they can also
make use of of the of the modelling that
we do and so the idea is to innovate
using data and it's important for the
regional news providers to remain
relevant there's so much news for so
much technology nowadays the regional
providers they must also use your data
to remain relevant for their audience
and have a very special role there are
really really regional news providers
and yet the way that we did this was
just by really and that that's actually
the main characteristic of this project
really by doing it so it just implements
the stuff so none of us is like
full-time committed on this project but
still we get together a couple of times
per month in Arnhem and we we just make
this happen and I think that's that's a
really cool part of it so this is us in
an old church in Arnhem or at least it's
me I think you were at more exotic
places at that time
other members of primes and repelled
loans and editor is sitting at the table
it's important that the editors are
actively involved as well because
they're going to use also the data
products that we develop picture was
taken by use for fire the project
manager we have a rich history with him
at the NPO actually Flint central was
talking about some of the stuff that he
did with him there so I'm really happy
to continue the collaboration three
different pilots we have implemented so
we made a news map we did some
experiments with different headlines
so variations of headlines for the same
news article and of course we made
recommendations and we'll elaborate and
it's free of those right now so this is
the news map so this is actually the the
most I would say free form data products
that we made for the editors of
coca-cola I don't have any hard results
or whatever on this it's just we hope
that they're going to use this so they
can see in the red dots where the
articles took place that they write so
in the in the content management system
they have to click on a map you know
accompanying the news article saying
okay this news applies to this place and
then you can see here an overview of
where the most articles are written and
where the users come from in blue who
actually read those articles and yeah
the idea is like for in this example you
immediately see that there's a blind
spot so there are whole regions of the
province that are not being covered so
you can immediately see that you can
make more relevant content by by writing
something about that region but yeah so
we have to see in to what extent they're
going to use it we just make sure that
this runs and it's efficient about
experimenting with different headlines
so the this feature was built to a
content management system so as opposed
to what they usually do just write a
headline for the news article there's
also the option to write an alternative
headline says you know it's funny they
have to think
think harder about what they could
alternatively maybe do and that whenever
they they derive to of the of those
headlines this is submitted also to
primes in the primed platform takes care
of surfing the the different headlines
two disjoint group of well by unbiased
groups of course and we you know the
screams for a bandit approach of course
to online find out what is what's the
best model but we currently have
separate it's like surfing the headlines
and collecting the metrics so we didn't
integrate it yet so instead we use an
old-school statistic saying that you
know after a couple of clicks on each of
the variants we are certain up to a
certain extent that the difference that
exists between two headlines is an
actual difference and this applies most
of the time but we've also seen this
week in the i-x match that the scale so
can go wrong but usually you're right
when you do such a thing and actually we
made some of our computations for the
month of March
by doing this more than thirteen
thousand more articles have been read
and so we're not interested in clicks
we're interested in article reads so
happy to see that articles are read more
frequently by using two different
headlines so if we would do this for the
whole catalog of all the news articles
this could increase to more than two
hundred thousand reads per month extra
for over twelve month and I think that's
that's a good result for them then of
course where we also make
recommendations so if you visit the
website you fist it a couple of times
then you see a couple of recommendations
for news articles and also here we focus
on like really quickly develop these
these models put it into production and
just measure how many articles are read
for each of the of the variants so not
gonna spent like weeks or I don't know
how much time making a very elaborate
algorithm with
so we just started with spark
collaborative filter and tried to put it
in production as fast as possible and
then just measure the the results but on
top of that right now what we have
running is also a time decay factor on
the scores so I expect the experiment
with a couple of time decay factors like
a Gaussian decay or linear decay we
didn't didn't want to do exponential you
know we we demoted the the articles of
the last couple of days we want dowse to
remain relevant it turned out in the
first set of experiments at the a
Gaussian decay with standard deviation
of three days for sexually satisfactory
for us and because it's a regional news
provider we think that the the the
geography also plays an important role
and we have the article location and
sometimes we also have the user location
so in this example if I was if I was the
one who was reading those yellow
articles then the article that would be
recommended to me by the geographic
recommend recommend er would be the one
that is closest and the current version
to the median location which I'm reading
this of course very simple approach so
next week we're going to put some more
elaborate algorithm for that online but
yeah this is what we have been
experimenting with and this is then how
I do it was my what my life looks like
when I'm working on this this is my
version of the primed architecture very
not very good as a death but so this is
the private platform so we use click aus
as a data warehousing over a database a
solution I can write Python packages
using PI spark that gets the data from
there which I can then install into the
docker images push that through a
registry and pull that on the Cuban AIDS
cluster in a my jobs to run my jobs on
the cluster and this is well pretty
pretty nice set up and run some Google
clouds although in principle your clouds
agnostic right
but I'm pretty happy with it and then
you know that the first thing you do of
course is pulling the data then it's up
to me to do some modeling in this case
it boils down to for certain device
insert the article compute a certain
score and then I can in interface two
primes so there's a Python API that I
can talk to and then I can just push the
the scores to that I compute it and I
can I can make experiments I can make a
campaigns I can create models I can give
names to those models and then all the
the feedback will be stored again in in
click house and then I can compute
metrics from this some results so we are
interested in the head in particular the
number of articles that have been read
and because we have currently
recommendations only on the home page we
have been measuring like the number of
clicks in the number of reads from the
home page so the articles can also be
sent via social channels for example now
you skip the home page but that we don't
take into account here we have a new
control group so that's a group of
people who don't get any recommendations
and we have a random control group that
gets well random recommendations of
course and what we see is you know if
you have if you have random
recommendations that already improves
over not having any recommendations and
then our best model until now which is a
basic level to filter from spark with a
time decay Gaussian time decay with 70
faces of three days on top of that
performs best so just the geoq geography
is not the best one yet
so that's well that's a pity but on the
website we are actually improving on the
number of reads in the number of clicks
on the website so that is nice and
actually you know right now we are we've
come to the to the situation that we
have all the components in place you
know in the mean time things have broken
and bugs have been fixed
etc and now
yeah we're really getting up to steam so
yeah we're gonna do a lot of modeling
there's still a lot of low-hanging fruit
that I can because I can eat so and for
example improve the geography
recommender because if you think of it
and if you look at this there is no such
thing as the location of an article or
of a user so or if this is certain user
it has been reading these articles so
instead of do a DB scan clustering you
know be robust against those outliers
identify a couple of clusters and then
there's my score on death and I have we
can use bandits here as well and we can
use the the text of the articles so all
that is still to be done and I believe
and hope that we can improve the the
metrics any further so this is then for
me the last slide to conclude before I
give the word traumatize so this is the
traffic and the unique devices per day
that we see on the website here we have
some issues with the data collection so
I hope you forgive me that I left these
out to a fit this linear trend and well
let's work hard to to keep this going as
it does mattias thank you very much
Evo let me try to not forget putting the
microphone down usually when I hold a
microphone and I end up keeping it down
at some point because I get too absorbed
in the story but please remind me if you
can't hear me so just let me start we've
seen right now we've seen what we're
doing at Phillip as well as the models
that Eva has been using to sort of
increase or obtain the goals that we've
been after and what I'm going to talk
about a little bit now is the
engineering that went into it so
basically to frame a little bit what I'm
going to talk about is we have basically
this what we call a data science loop
where we have a user at the top where it
all starts and the user essentially
exposes behavior to us that we can
collect this data this data we
evaluate our KPI zones such as
click-through rate or read through rates
if we want to know how many articles a
user actually ends up reading to the end
and we use this information so we use
these KPIs and that data to train models
now once we've trained these models
we're not entirely there yet we need to
put these models into production or
deploy them so that they can find their
way back to the end-user
so today I'll just be talking about two
steps and mainly on the delivery step at
the top so bringing the model
predictions to an end user is what I
call delivery and it'll be the topic of
of this talk so when a Philip came to us
in the end
go data driven and primes they had two
questions so the first thing was that
they wanted to be able to iterate
quickly they said okay it's really great
if you guys can come up with one model
but we don't really know if that model
will be sort of describing behavior
properly so instead of having one model
we'd want to be able to try various
different models one after the other and
do that very quickly so we can learn
from each generation and improve as we
go now the other thing is that there
were multiple use cases so we're talking
recommendations right now we're talking
about different titles so if you come
onto the page you might see the same
articles as someone else but you might
get different titles so these two
aspects of the question sort of drove
drove our efforts into engineering the
solution now another few small details
when you think of regional broadcasters
or regional news you might make the
mistake of thinking that it's small
volume but in reality we see about 1,500
one point five million unique visitors
every week and there's about 2,000
articles being published we also have a
lot of peaks in our traffic because as
push notifications go out we can see
that you know Peaks of 14,000 requests
per minute are not unusual
it says RPS but that should be rpm
actually
so the the challenge becomes to serve
this type of traffic whilst maintaining
low latencies because if a user comes
into the page and then the
recommendations are being served to them
ten seconds later what we're a bit too
late right so we're adhering to about a
hundred milliseconds at p99 SLA and I
want to talk about some approaches that
we tried and the one that we eventually
sort of settled on so our first approach
was this one very simple I think this is
the the baseline sort of how you go from
a model and deploying that to production
and you have your user generating your
data and you use that to craft a model
in an iterative process offline and well
we figured that a good way of bringing
that to an online environment would be
to talk arise the model put it behind
the REST API and to allow the client
that the user is logged into this could
be a web browser or mobile app to
perform rest calls to the API and then
to get a score back I mean that sounds
very reasonable but there's a big
problem with this approach and actually
the big problem is that as a conceptual
mismatch so if I put my model online in
this way and I have a collaborative
filter I'm not really going to get a
list of recommendations back what i'm
going to get back is a probability that
this user and item combination is is
considered relevant a prediction that
this user will find this item relevant
but if my use case is to show a number
of recommendations so a list of
recommendations it will not do that i
have a probability between a user and an
item so there's a conceptual problem
here and it's not just that it's also
when i start solving this problem and i
say ok well my api then just needs to
loop over the articles that I have and
then sort of score that particular user
for all the combinations of articles
that we have it becomes really difficult
to guarantee these Layton sees that we
we need to adhere to Plus that it
becomes very difficult to sort of keep
in mind
you know when the new articles are being
published or they're being mutated or
they're being deleted to sort of make
sure that our API keeps up to date with
this sort of process so we came up with
a different design it has its own flaws
but what we came up with and Evo
actually sort of went over it a little
bit is that we still have the user
generating data that we collect and that
we or EVO actually can use to generate
models craft models but now we have a
step in the middle where we need to
score the model we pre calculate all the
possible combinations that might occur
and we store these in a prediction store
say Redis and now actually when I do a
rest call I have a conceptual match I
can get a list back is that so I've gone
from having to call the API using
actually a user ID and an item ID to get
back a predicted relevance between this
combination I've gone to being able to
call the API when a user hits the home
page and give back a list of
recommendations so another very nice
property of this is that I can now
guarantee blatant C's and it's
relatively easy to scale this seller so
to set up so now I can deal with my
14,000 requests per minute
the only problem obviously is that I've
introduced another Pro another very
expensive process which is having to
calculate all these different
combinations of uses and items but then
when I think about it I don't really
need to do that either I can just take
why I can so I need to still calculate
them but I can take the top 10 or the
top 20 and store those in my prediction
store or my Redis and basically when I
do this I have these nice properties of
guaranteed latency for easy scalability
to be able to deal with the very large
peaks of in in traffic while still
maintaining a conceptual match to what I
was trying to achieve so we balance
these two approaches we said okay we can
serialize our models
and make sure that they end up in the
docker container and then we put them
behind the rest API we chose not to do
to these conceptual mismatch and the
difficult guarantees on load latency and
instead opted for the caching approach
and again it's expensive to calculate
but that's why tools like SPARC exist
and cache is a memory heavy solution but
if you can deal with a level of sparsity
in your in your predictions matrix it's
it's something that can be dealt with so
this is our general architecture we have
our user towards the left interacting
with their device the device in the end
calls an API now the user may at this
point be either opening a page or
reading through an article and we
collect these events and we store them
in our event datastore that we make
available to - Evo - very to discern any
patterns and visually query the data
then a modeling process flow follows
which is in Jupiter notebook in this
case but it could be an R based approach
or anything else the results are being
stored in this caching layer and this
caching layer is exposed through the
same API that we have for collecting the
data and what is what is really nice
about this flow is that it allows us to
both send out recommendations and
alternative titles to the user as well
as collects their response to this so
this feedback loop that I was showing up
here at the beginning of my slides comes
back into this story and it allows us to
basically continuously evaluate the
performance of each different type of
model that we have a line and compare
those and to iteratively learn from from
our mistakes and and to hope we get
better so in summary I think a Philips
ambitions are very high I think it's
pretty cool for any organization to
aspire to this type of this level of
personalization
I'm very glad to be a part of that
actually and to be able to work with
smart people like Evo and all the other
people that we have the ratio up
I think the first generation models the
results are quite promising we're not
there yet but we've built a system that
we can sort of we've started a road
where we can start iterating on better
and better and better models all the
time and hopefully in a year we'll be
able to present way better results than
than what we have now and I think it's
important to note as a final note that
delivering models to the end-user is
crucial so just like Evo said you can
spend months training and creating a
perfect model of line but until it hits
your end-users it doesn't exist and I
think we've done this here and I'm very
proud of that any questions
[Applause]